mir geht's gut aber kannst du bitte auf
nämlich so anzug klotzen
ach so ja natürlich entschuldigung an
etwas glaubt netz bekommen beim ein
video erst mal kurz vorweg bevor es
losgeht meine haare habe ich gerade
frisch gemacht die sind noch ein
bisschen was sie sind nicht fertig das
wollte ich einfach mal kurz loswerden
bevor es losgeht ja durch und es ist
wirklich lange her dass mein letztes
jungs mädchen thema kam und ich hab
keinen bock drauf deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht komm hause doch einfach mein
part von irgendwas raus und letztes mal
kamen glaube ich anzeichen dass er mehr
möchte als freund ausgleich gibt und ich
hab euch da natürlich mal wieder
aufgefordert in die kommentare zu
schreiben was ihr noch von mir hören
wollt was die jungs mädchen angeht das
schreibt am besten auch direkt jetzt mal
in die kommentare
18 em sorry dass ich jetzt wieder so
viel aber aber was ganz wichtig ist ich
habe eine facebook seite neu aufgestellt
man das team auf jeden fall an alle die
von euch facebook haben habe ich jetzt
wirklich coole sache und zu habe ich auf
facebook gerade so 10030 habe facebook
noch nie wirklich benutzt aber facebook
kommt jetzt facebook wird durchgezogen
und deswegen habe ich mir was krasses
überlegt was wirklich krass ist und zwar
habe ich ja hier hinten eine playstation
4 ich weiß nicht wie habt ihr
wahrscheinlich schon mal gesehen oder so
keine ahnung dazu auch noch zwei
controller auch noch ein paar ganz coole
spiele kann ich eigentlich mal kurz
zeigen wo sind die
wenn ich gerade dumm oder ist die kamera
unterwegs ist passiert naja egal auf
jeden fall habe ich einmal vorlaut das
ist so ein ballerspiel dann einmal fifa
16 4 17 hab ich zerstört das sind jetzt
die einzigen beiden die ich gefunden
habe aber im endeffekt geht es ja auch
erstmal die playstation wir auf jeden
fall die facebook seite von mir ist ganz
oben in der video beschreibung verlinkt
unter den ersten 25.000 blei kann also
auch die die jetzt schon gelegt haben
zählen auch dazu wird alles hier verlost
also die playstation die für spieler die
beiden controller und das ganze werde
ich in verbindung setzen mit bei miss
russia schon wieder runter auf jeden
fall kommt jetzt endlich in spätestens
zehn tage meinen merge raus und wenn das
nicht passiert dann weiß ich auch nicht
mehr aber es muss einfach passieren wenn
ich dann gilt das natürlich trotzdem ich
werde auf jeden fall die playstation 4
dann persönlich meinetwegen auch
unterschrieben und drauf gespuckt mit
das ist übertrieben
ihr wisst was ich meine ich werde
persönlich vorbeibringen das ganze werde
ich auch aufnehmen
das wird kein fake also denkt jetzt
nicht fähig oder sollte wirklich unter
den ersten 25.000 like an wird das hier
alles verlost playstation spiele
controller eigentlich alles zusammen
keine aber mal sehen
das einzige was sie tun muss ist die
facebook-seite like ich benutze deshalb
wirklich nicht mehr deswegen habe ich
mir gesagt komm das kannst du machen ist
war ein wert von 300 euro oder so da
vielleicht nur 250 aber wen juckt sich
mein ich mache ja youtube auf jeden fall
kommen wir jetzt zurück zum thema und
zwar ungefähr zwei wochen die fidor
oscar und anzeichen dass er mehr möchte
als freundschaft und die hat in die
kommentare geschrieben was ihr noch
sehen wollt und viele meinen nein mach
einfach das gegenteil und haben mir dazu
auch ein paar kommentare geschrieben die
mir echt helfen zum beispiel der
kommentar von als wir machen halt heute
anzeichen dass ein mädchen mehr möchte
als freundschaft und ja da hab ich halt
wie schon oben erwähnt ein paar super
kommentare von euch bekommen zum
beispiel der kommentar von anti social
tv anzeichen dafür dass sie nur
freundschaft will ich wenn sie sagt ich
will nur freundschaft dank mir später da
kann man auf jeden fall mal wieder
klatschen das den kommentar solche
kommentare das spricht ja immer wieder
an solche kommentare brauche ich du hast
natürlich an sich recht aber was ist
wenn man milch hin sich nicht traut zu
sagen ich möchte nur freundschaften
irgendwie
mädchen sind ja zum teil schüchtern was
passiert dann
deswegen mache ich dieses video deswegen
danke an jojo sie schreibt anzeichen
dass ein mädel mädel kann man sagt mir
dass heutzutage noch auf jeden fall dass
ein mädchen mehr will als freundschafts
typischen sprüche wie bohr du bist so
doof ganz ehrlich ja das kenne ich das
kenne ich so gut ich will wirklich eins
zu eins hinter deiner meinung dass war
will den kommentar der könnte auch von
mir kommen
ich weiss kam er nicht aber auch immer
diese typischen beleidigung oder man
wird einfach so arschloch genannt als
junge wo ich mir denke hey warum ich
denn jetzt so aber da ist dann halt
immer dieser gewisse so man weiß als
junge so halt wisst ihr was ich meine
ist auch egal wir machen einfach mal
schnell weiter und zwar schreibt luki
girl mädchen schauen den jungen den sie
mögen immer in die augen wenn sie mit
ihm reden
ja ich bin alex und du ich bin die
schränke interessant freue mich dich
kennenzulernen ja danke freut mich auch
sehr wie geht es dir den tut mir geht es
gut aber kannst du bitte auch für mich
so an zu putzen
ach so ja natürlich tschuldigung ich
weiß natürlich wie das meint aber ich
finds auch komisch wenn ich die ganze
zeit so angeglotzt werden na ja wir
machen einfach mal weiter mit drei
punkten die ich mir persönlich noch ein
fallengelassen haben einfallen lassen
habt genau auf jeden fall ich weiß
natürlich nicht ob das so stimmt aber es
sind halt einfach vermutung von mir weil
ich mein ich bin ja kein mädchen und
deswegen kann das halt sein muss aber
nicht das könnt ihr einfach mal in die
kommentare schreiben wie ihr so dazu
stellt punkt nummer 1 also man ist so
einfach zu zweit zu halten eigentlich
auf freundschaftlicher basis
und die zieht sich vor dir einfach oben
da freut sich natürlich jeder junge sehr
drüber aber so eigentlich ist das doch
ein zeichen dafür dass sie entweder was
ganz bestimmtes sucht oder halt dich so
beeindrucken möchte also dass wir
wirklich so sofort ein kopf bekommen
aber jetzt gerade denke ich so es könnte
vielleicht auch sein dass ihr das macht
weil er ja nur befreundet sein
keine ahnung aber der nächste punkt
stimmt wirklich zu 100 prozent auf jeden
fall wenn ein mädchen wo ihr denkt so ja
das ist schon meine freundin
plötzlich die ganze zeit davon erzählt
was sie so in zukunft mit ihr vorhat
also wirklich so sagt soja in zwei
monaten lasst uns mal nach paris fahren
und in drei monaten lasst uns mal nach
dahin fahren und in fünf monaten das uns
mal zusammen ziehen und in sechs monaten
lasst uns war kind lachen und sieben
monaten lasst uns mal heil das weil es
übertrieben aber so halt einfach euch
die ganze zeit in irgendwelche pläne von
sich selber einbindet obwohl man ja
eigentlich nur befreundet ist oder das
dann halt so sagt soja zumal es wäre
doch schön wenn wir mal einen
zusammenhang versteht was ich meine ich
glaube das habe ich gut heraus gefunden
oder und leute kommen wir zum letzten
punkt und zwar ist das ähnlich wie beim
letzten video hab ich ja gesagt wenn ein
junger immer mit euch kaufen will dann
erhofft er sich vielleicht dadurch was
und andersrum könnte ich mir vielleicht
vorstellen wenn ein mädchen immer mit
euch feiern gehen möchte erhofft sie
sich was weil es macht ja schließlich
auch voll sind oder nicht ich meine man
kann das natürlich von zwei
verschiedenen seiten sehen so ich gehe
zur zeit auch sehr sehr gerne noch
feiern aber wirklich nur wegen der musik
so weit ich halt gerade so viel neue
musik für mich entdecke und ja das war's
halt viel spaß ich bin wirklich immer so
voll auf die musik konzentriert und
sofort zwei jahren als ich war single
war oder so kenne ich das natürlich auch
ist man wegen anderen dingen da
hingegangen ist aber dann halt so zum
mainstream scheiß partys you understand
what i mean
deutschland würde ich mal sagen das
war's erst mal mit diesem video wie
gesagt vergesst auf keinen fall des
facebook gewinnspiel also ganz oben in
der video beschreibung meine facebook
seite verlinkt an sonst würde ich sagen
wir sehen uns morgen wieder 19 uhr
krasses neues video waren kommt wirklich
ein krasses video weil wir uns halt
ausgleichs gibt die nächste folge
hiervon also halt nächste jungs mädchen
thema und so schreibt eure wünsche ihr
habt was man ansprechen soll was jungs
und mädchen liebe relationship
beziehungen geschlechtsverkehr und so
weiter betrifft dann schreibt es einfach
in die kommentare
wir sehen uns morgen ich freue mich auf
euch rein jackman in sound snapshot
peace